oh hey welcome to the monitor I am
senior editor Peter Rubin and first up
this week this actually came out last
week but because there was so much other
great stuff last week I didn't get to
talk about but it is on bookshelves now
it is Volume one of the graphic canon
compiled and edited by russ kick but
what it actually is is a collection it's
going to be I believe a three-volume
collection though it might be five I
check it later don't worry about it all
of the world's great literature as
imagined donat reinterpreted by graphic
artists and writers so in this first
volume will eisner contribute something
Robert Crumb contributes something it's
everything from Beowulf to Bosworth
London journal it's really ambitious and
phenomenal and there's a lot of naughty
bits if that's why you like to read
graphic novels you know I'm much more
high-minded than that but at any rate
it's out comic shops fine bookstores by
all means pick this up it's really
really pretty amazing but to talk about
movies we're going to go to my
correspondent in the field because
that's what we do hmm Thanks okay this
week in movies Snow White and the
Huntsman is out looks awesome thing
about this is there were two snow white
movies that came out this year and one
came out and didn't do very well and
then this one came out this one looks
like it's by that guy tarsem who did who
did the cell and he did the fall and he
just makes these visually unbelievable
movies it looks like he did this one but
weirdly he actually did the other one
the guy who did this one is some guy
named rupert sanders has never done a
movie before I don't know why I'm so mad
right now Rupert Sanders first-time
director but he did some really cool
nike commercials and scott charlize
theron and chris hemsworth and kristen
stewart and why me even saying these
peoples names you know
all this already so instead let's just
do the haiku review of the week it's not
by tarsem but it looks like it's by him
good enough for me back to you last up
this week is video games but actually
before that last night began in season 3
of workaholics on comedy central no
reason to get into it I love the show
because I'm an idiot you should too the
mail order comedy guys fantastic season
3 watch or at least catch up and then
watch or something but video games so
yesterday came well it's not really a
new game batman arkham city came out
last november but Arkham City game of
the year edition came out yesterday so
if you miss the game the first time
around there's just no excuse this is
something you have to get not only is it
the game which wired had in its top
three of the games of 2011 but you get
all the dlc that came out after the
game's release Catman Nightwing Robin
but there's the challenge pack that came
out for the game and then there's also
something all-new called Harley Quinn's
revenge which a story based content that
they didn't really give too much away
about but by the time you're seeing this
I've already played it just haven't
played it yet while we're taping a
little bit behind the curtain that's
kind of TV magic for you but that's it
for the monitor will be back next week
with more fantastic can't miss pop
culture stuff inspirational catchphrase
here
you